uh you're looking at Graceland in
Memphis Tennessee right now that's where
more than 1 000 mourners honored Lisa
Marie Presley at her funeral yesterday
Elvis Presley's only child whose little
girl died 11 days ago she was laid to
rest at Graceland that's a Presley home
alongside other family members Elise
Preston is outside Graceland with more
on this story Elise good morning to you
I heard that by the time it was all over
more than 5 000 people passed through
the gates to pay their respects
[Music]
uh definitely a huge crowd here good
morning to you Gail and definitely an
emotional service as the Presley family
friends and thousands of fans gathered
here at the former home of Elvis to pay
their respects and say goodbye to his
beloved daughter Lisa Marie
on the front lawn of Graceland hundreds
gathered for a memorial service filled
with love and music
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
celebrate least Marie Presley's life
Lisa Marie Presley was an icon a role
model a superhero to many people all
over the world her mother Priscilla
Presley remembered the 54 year old with
short remarks and a poem from Lisa
Marie's daughter Harper Lockwood now she
is home where she always belonged but my
heart is missing her love born in
Memphis Presley was immediately part of
Music royalty she grew up at Graceland
and was just nine when Elvis died at the
Mansion her spirit will live in the
collective memory
of a city
that loved her tinderling
loved her sweetness
and loved her truly after the service
silent somber moments in the meditation
Garden where Presley is now laid to rest
next to her son Benjamin Keough who died
by suicide in 2020 as mourners passed
her grave some paused to touch the
singer-songwriter's final resting place
others laid flowers They Carried through
line for hours including Angela Lewis
Stevens pieces are famous they made us
feel like we were their family Louis
arrived at two in the morning Sunday to
make sure she had her chance to say
goodbye honoring the love of a father
and his little girl she and he are
currently still alive
[Music]
now Lisa Marie and Elvis both touched
the fans from across the world and their
legacy will continue through the Next
Generation during the memorial service
yesterday Lisa Marie's daughter Riley
Keough revealed that she had given birth
to a baby girl the announcement made by
Riley's husband reads in part I hope I
can love my daughter the way you love me
the way you love my brother and my
sisters thank you for giving me strength
my heart my empathy now Riley was at the
memorial service yesterday it is unclear
when she gave birth Tony
hmm Elise thank you very much it's a
family they've seen so much tragedy
that's a bit of good news there but the
circle of life continues in the Presley
family you know it's something to see
the iconic pictures of Lisa Marie and
the shot of her with their little
pigtails and her dad smiling at each
other it's very very hard to see but
it's also there's something very
touching that she's now with her son and
that she's now with her father as as
hard as this is I think about Priscilla
Presley no Mom should ever have to read
at your at your child's funeral that's
very difficult to see and you're right
they've known so much tragedy in
particular yeah I heard today yes yes
all right at least thank you again for
that report